you could think of anybody you know that
shouldn't be there just let me know and
I'll get them on the list
awesome what if it's just like cocktail
yeah it's kind of just like cocktails
everyone's gonna mingle a little and I'm
gonna present it to them for the first
time so all right I'll do that
alright bye who's that those boo boom oh
I shouldn't see if she was coming to the
stop-attack launch party stop-attack is
an emergency assault Adam you could
record a moment where you feel that you
are in need of help or that somebody
else's needed help and immediately you
can notify the authorities a lot of
things like this kind of don't get
enough attention right word of mouth but
if you do a photo campaign - I think
that alone via social media yes you're
starting today with that right think of
yours the photo campaign for stop-attack
is very simple you write down on your
hand what you want stop in this world
you post the picture using the hashtag
stopattack challenge and challenge your
friends to spread the word are you
having a lot of people showing up yeah
well I invited some celeb friends just
like some close friends and people that
I meet that will actually add media is
gonna be there well the app is fantastic
yeah it's really it's very useful and
it's gonna be like you know in case of
emergency I think it's great I wanted to
figure out some really cool ways to get
it out to the world so I felt like
having an event for and bringing some of
my closest friends as well as opening it
up to some of the public would be a
great way to do so initially when I
first came in contact with you know
stop-attack I was like wow this could be
really cool for some kid who just
doesn't know what to do or some somebody
who wants to help somebody else in this
situation I think it could save people's
who are exactly right a thing about it
is somebody records it on this app you
can either immediately notify leave the
police you could put like five people on
a contact list that are like immediate
emergency like here I want these people
to get it so if you just press the
button and it'll straight to them that's
great yeah I thought about even when you
know I
was in that you know abusive
relationship back to the day I remember
he instilled that fear in you that if
you left him he would hurt us and
because of that you stayed in it but
like literally to the point where you
know you almost lost your life I am so
proud of her for doing stuff attack this
is something that she could connect with
and I'm glad she's going to help others
because honestly if someone maybe if she
would have been able to tape him back in
the day we would have had evidence you
had bruises and you were covering them
up all the time
I was hardest thing to go through was
watching you then so long since I've
even thought about it it was so hard to
deal with you being like that he just
kept staying a mother to sit there think
that any day now I was gonna get that
phone call that you were gone it's one
of the hardest thing as a parent is to
watch your child go through an abuse and
she was a grown adult who just kept
choosing to go back